[Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  why was our quran at the foot of a deity  that's why we are protesting quran  belongs to all of us we can't tolerate  the defamation of the quran  [Music]  there are some groups who are quite  negative who are not patriots i would  say so this  category of people  have tried  to tarnish  the image of our  nation which  has been  a classic example around the world about  mulching culturalism  multi-religious coexistence  there are heavy presence of security  forces across the country government and  security agencies have described the  recent incident as planned with the aim  of destabilizing the country  [Music]  [Music]  things are fine in our locality we feel  totally safe and there are no bad  incidents happening here however we do  feel really bad that some incidents did  take place it's just not right whoever  did all these things  [Applause]  [Music]  you